what's fair buddy we're calm Finity and
welcome to another episode of challenge
community this the series were you
challenge us with your craziest ideas
right at the table Venice if your idea
gets picked we'll give you a shout-out
and feature in our next video so make
sure you leave their comments and ideas
in the comment section below
anthem guy Chuck is wondering if it's
possible to serve around the net let's
find out since it wasn't possible to do
it with a normal table we did have to
add some length
[Applause]
[Music]
Rohan Porter wants to play with
shuttlecock instead of a racket I think
we thought we'll have no chance against
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Roger often wants us to smashes on two
tables
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the jar single wants to see us play with
a coat hanger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
episode make sure to leave it a thumbs
up and if you lose your channel remember
to subscribe here and watch our other
videos here until next time
[Applause]